notre envoyé spécial elena volochine
elle se trouve à koursk à côté d'eux
karkhiv elena j'espère que vous n'en
entendez bien quelles sont les dernières
informations dont vous disposez une
offensive et est toujours en cours à
kharkhiv
alors les informations dont je dispose
la leçon à fait inquiétant qui me suis
entretenu avec l'ours par un militaire
qui m'a affirmé que tout toutes les
autres structures militaires les
notamment les postes de commandement les
aéroports militaires ont été arrêtés
d'après cette source bombardé en ukraine
que les troupes aéroportées serait
descendu à marioupol et au d'état
également dans la ville de kharkiv donc
effectivement dans la région le côté de
la frontière où je me trouve
cette source m'a également affirmé que
une fois cette opération
de sabotage des
détritus remet leopard et craignent
elles réalisées notamment la destruction
aussi annoncée par la russie de la la
défense en quelques lignes elle est bien
un ultimatum serait posée à alarmer le
craignait de se rendre et déposer les
dames elena volochine le président
biélorusse a convoqué il ya quelques
minutes les chefs de son armée ont peut
dire que l'ukraine est encerclé par la
mer la mer d'azov l'accès à la mer
d'azov a été fermée par moscou l'ukraine
donc qui est encerclée la lance
l'encerclement se confirme l'étau se
resserre de toutes parts autour de
l'ukraine
oui c'est exactement cela et cette
offensive elle est beaucoup plus
importante que celle que que l'on
envisageait dans les pires scénarios
même ces derniers jours on supposer un
essai à un encerclement de la partie est
du pays
via la biélorussie vous venez de le dire
bien la région de kharkiv via la région
de belgorod
côté russe via aussi le sud et l'est le
dombass direction marioupol on ne
s'attendait pas du tout à ce que des
troupes aéroportées
soit soit descendu à l'ouest de
l'ukraine notamment à eau d'état
et
les sourds paramilitaires me faisait
état d'une augmenté du ce cognac roulait
pas trop y croire parce que maintenant
elle est déjà énorme
aujourd'hui apparemment même dante
souffre avait sous-estimé le scénario et
il semblerait que qu'il y ait l'ambition
de prendre de prendre toute l'ukraine
avec notamment c'est que c'était
possible et le petit matin après après
cette opération aérienne
merci lna